mi chiamo massimo e sono un ingegnere
meccanico che lavora in un'azienda di
pressofusione
quindi di di rete perché stasera oggi se
qui a parlare di legalità perché finita
l'università a siena un gruppo di amici
curiosi come me
abbiamo cominciato a chiederci come mai
di alcuni argomenti soprattutto sulla
stampa locale non si parlasse mai o
quasi mai primo fra tutti quello delle
infiltrazioni mafiose
e dire che dieci anni fa arrivava la
prima condanna per associazione mafiosa
nel nostro territorio e arrivava
esattamente per un omicidio avvenuto
vicino a noi nel cervese
gabriele guerra un ragazzo più o meno
come me crivellato da colpi di
mitraglietta skorpio in pieno giorno in
strada a pinarella per motivi legati
alla droga o alle bische clandestine
e una vera e propria scena da film ma
nessuno o pochi ne parlavano allora è
venuta la curiosità di studiare e di
informarsi di capire di conoscere poi di
scrivere articoli dossier e di fare
questa attività con tante altre realtà
della nostra regione arrivando a
realizzare un sito internet che si
chiama mafia sotto casa
in cui con semplici puntatori siamo
andati a mappare e geolocalizzare tutti
i fatti di mafia avvenuti nella nostra
regione
perché se è vero che
mettere il tema delle infiltrazioni
mafiose al centro del dibattito pubblico
al nord è ancora molto difficile è
altrettanto vero che le infiltrazioni
mafiose e le mafie al nord sono attive
da decenni e decenni è fin dagli anni 80
che tutta la penisola è attraversata da
omicidi di mafia
era il 1980 quando in sicilia veniva
ucciso pier santi mattarella
ma era al 1982 quando veniva ucciso
sempre dalla mafia il magistrato bruno
caccia ma a torino
è dagli anni 80 in poi le leggi
antimafia fortunatamente si sono evolute
si sono moltiplicate rendendo l'italia
effettivamente un paese all'avanguardia
da questo punto di vista da tanti anni
poi sono nati i percorsi di legalità
nelle scuole con i bambini con le
bambine e la bibliografia è piena di
esempi e di buone pratiche di questo
tipo nei comuni nelle regioni nascono i
protocolli per la legalità
i coordinamenti alla legalità
addirittura gli assessorati alla
legalità
quindi va tutto bene e ho chiuso
l'intervento qui no prendiamo qualche
numero per capire l'istat dice che
l'italia ha un'economia sommersa di
210 miliardi di euro ogni anno
facciamo un termine di paragone attuale
è come se ogni anno un intero recovery
fund venisse gestito in maniera illegale
tutti gli anni anno dopo anno
quando giovanni falcone veniva chiesto è
possibile si può parlare di emergenza
mafia lui rispondeva sempre no non si
può parlare di emergenza mafia perché
siamo di fronte a un problema endemico
del nostro paese e l'illegalità e dati
alla mano ancora oggi un problema
endemico della nostra società
ma cosa significa quindi
legalità
quando mi è capitato di porre questa
domanda alle scuole ragazzi e le ragazze
la prima risposta è sempre stata il
rispetto delle leggi semplice
siamo sicuri che sia così
siamo sicuri che sia questo il giusto
concetto di legalità
provo a farvi un esempio
italia anni settanta articolo 544 del
codice penale
per i delitti preveduti dal capo primo
ed all'articolo 530 il matrimonio che
l'autore del reato contragga con la
persona offesa estingue il reato
anche riguardo a coloro che sono
concorsi nel reato medesimo e se vi è
stata condanna né cessano l'esecuzione e
gli effetti penali
quindi a chi violentava o stuprava una
ragazza ma poi era disposto a sposarla
veniva estinto il reato
era giusto era giusto il mero
perseguimento dei fini di legge è questo
il giusto concetto che diamo alla parola
legalità
evidentemente al mio bisogno altrimenti
non sarei qui questa sera ma legalità
deve certamente è obbligatoriamente
prevedere il rispetto di norme di legge
sono la base del vivere civile in una
società democratica come la nostra ma
deve significare anche qualcosa di più
qualsiasi cittadino ha bisogno di
comprendere quelli che sono i valori
fondamentali del vivere civile per
vivere in maniera coscienziosa ma anche
attiva sviluppare il senso delle regole
dell'etica della morale
creare rapporti e interazioni di fiducia
con gli altri cittadini e con le
istituzioni
ma come può un cittadino direte voi
barcamenarsi nella selva oscura della
legislazione italiana
sapete che si stima che in italia vi
siano
160.000 norme di cui 71 mila emanate a
livello centrale le restanti a livello
locale regionale
faccio qualche esempio in francia si
stima siano 7 mila in germania
5.500 nel regno unito solo 3000
questa selva oscura di norme di legge a
mio avviso provoca due effetti chiari da
un lato
il semplice cittadino come chiunque di
noi si trova ad andare incontro ad una
serie di problemi burocratici
lungaggini nelle risposte
norme contraddittorie e regole talvolta
difficile o addirittura impossibili da
applicare
dall'altro lato però
questo groviglio normativo
diventa un assist per tutti coloro che
agiscono
aggirando la legge per semplice
tornaconto personale
tutto questo però viene esaltato in
maniera esponenziale
nelle situazioni di emergenza
qualsiasi emergenza in cui diventa
vitale il fattore tempo e si creano le
condizioni per fare le cose in deroga
le mafie tutte le mafie sono legate a
doppio filo a questa parolina magica e
emergenza
vi ricordate il terremoto che colpì
l'emilia romagna qualche anno fa quella
fu l'occasione per mettere in piedi un
sistema di controllo delle aziende
tramite white list un sistema ottimo ma
all'epoca poco ha finanziato e quindi
poco supportato da una struttura tecnica
economica capace di distinguere in tempi
rapidi le aziende pulite dalle aziende
di geo o addirittura nere a queste
lungaggini nelle risposte ma la
necessità emergenziale di spostare
tonnellate di detriti
risposero le aziende legate ai clan che
già erano presenti sul nostro territorio
e che riuscirono quindi ad accaparrarsi
parecchi lavori talmente tanti che
secondo poi una denuncia della cgil
almeno un terzo
delle macerie del terremoto
sarebbe stato spostato da aziende
illegali
talvolta aziende che non possedevano
nemmeno un mezzo di trasporto
ma anche il post terremoto
è stato funestato da infiltrazioni
mafiose e illegalità
durante la ricostruzione sono state
scoperte cose abbastanza inquietanti in
alcune zone dell'emilia l'amianto invece
di essere smaltito veniva miscelato con
terre da scavo andando a realizzare un
materiale da costruzione naturalmente
velenoso e meno resistente che ne ha poi
utilizzato per concludere gli appalti
della ricostruzione anche le strutture
pubbliche scuole ad esempio ci sono i
video che dimostrano come si sgretola il
muro delle scuole questa vicenda ha
avuto un esito curioso a livello
giudiziario perché una delle persone
indagate e poi condannate si chiama
augusto bianchini condannato in via
definitiva cioè primo secondo grado per
concorso esterno in associazione mafiosa
ma assolto da tutti quelli reati che
riguardano la vicenda amianto
quindi per la legge il rispetto delle
leggi per la legge l'amianto ha
dimostrato che c'è all'interno delle
strutture altero di zone pubbliche
ma si è dimostrato che non gliela messo
nessuno praticamente
ora di fronte a questo paradosso
stiamo ancora però vivendo un momento e
nostra azione di emergenza
e l'attenzione deve essere alta
altissima
nella realtà il problema è più grave
perché stiamo vivendo due emergenze non
una sola
da un lato c'è l'emergenza sanitaria e
lì le infiltrazioni mafiose hanno già
messo lo zampino
l'operazione pharma business recente ha
visto l'arresto di esponenti legati alla
ndrangheta
anche in emilia romagna che si
occupavano della distribuzione
all'ingrosso di farmaci di medicinali vi
è poi anche un'emergenza economica
derivata dalla crisi sanitaria
e anche qui campanelli d'allarme sono
altissimi
tanto che 10 delle 13 recenti
interdittive antimafia emesse dal
prefetto di rimini riguardano
quel settore turismo e ristorazione che
sono più in difficoltà i più colpiti
dalla crisi sanitaria quindi più
attenzionati dalle mafie
in italia mafie poteri forti corruzione
hanno creato un sistema attorcigliato di
legalità e zone grigie tollerate
arrivando a una legittimazione
strisciante di questo sistema e perfino
a una quasi tolleranza
non voglio parlare però solo di mafia e
di grande criminalità organizzata ma
anche di quelle criminalità che ci
possono sembrare in un primo momento
minori come quelle legate al fisco ad
esempio o anche a i ruoli imparziali di
chi che ha e chi ricopre ruoli pubblici
ad esempio come politici magistrati
poliziotti ma anche ruoli privati notai
commercialisti imprenditori
e su questo vorrei farvi un esempio
ragionando per assurdo
se da me al lavoro mi si presentasse un
potenziale cliente con un'idea
innovativa
materiali leggeri applicati alla
mobilità sostenibile per esempio io
farei i salti di gioia
splendido al termine dell'incontro
tecnico però potrebbe capitare che il
potenziale cliente mi dicesse poi però
facciamo tutto nero e io a quel punto
comincerei a spiegargli le differenze
tra verniciatura a polvere verniciatura
a liquido trattamenti superficiali e lui
ridendo mi interrompe mi dovrebbe
interrompere dicendo no no manzoli lei
non ha capito nulla
io intendo dire che ma non mi interessa
discutere del pagamento 30 60 90 giorni
delle fatture
a me interessa che voi mi date la merce
e io vengo qui con una valigetta piena
di banconote
come dovrei reagire
cosa dovrei fare io dovrei sorridere
accettando quasi normalità di quella
situazione
dovrei denunciare ma denunciare sulla
base di cosa poi
e andando incontro quali conseguenze
vedo delle facce stupite ma sono certo
che la stragrande maggioranza di voi
situazioni di questo tipo magari più
piccole o più grandi li abbia già viste
e vissute nella sua vita è la risposta
che noi abbiamo dato in quel preciso
istante è semplicemente dettata dal
livello in cui noi abbiamo deciso di
mettere l'asticella della legalità
a queste situazioni private poi spesso
si aggiunge anche la politica stessa che
talvolta sembra legittimare l'illegalità
o realizzando la o sostenendola
indirettamente
mantenendo posizioni ambigue su fatti di
vitale importanza per la vita
democratica del paese
gli esempi justicè storici sono la p2 i
tentativi di golpe tutti gli
insabbiamenti nelle vicende oscure
legate al terrorismo e alle stragi degli
anni 70 80 90
tutto questo sistema ha prodotto e
continua a produrre quella sensazione di
impotenza di abitudine
si perde la voglia la capacità di
opporsi di ribellarsi di resistere
si arriva a normalizzare tutto ea
considerare normale questo sistema
tollerando lo è ancora peggio
legittimandolo
pensate che nella recentissima sentenza
della cassazione del tribunale di
bologna
sul processo black monkey che raccontava
fatti legati al gioco d'azzardo avvenuti
anche in bassa romagna sono i giudici
a dire che è normale in alcuni settori
correlare su aver a che fare con
sodalizi criminali
a questo è un passaggio importante non è
più massimo manzoli non è più
l'associazione antimafia di turno ma
sono i giudici quindi il tribunale
stesso lo stato
ad alzare bandiera bianca ea scrivere
nero su bianco
che in taluni settori e naturale
correlarsi con le organizzazioni mafiose
e questa correlazione essendo naturale
non può più essere un'aggravante per
coloro che fanno quei reati li
questa è l'ulteriore conferma di ciò che
raccontavo prima che diceva giovanni
falcone in italia è naturale avere a che
fare con le mafie
il problema è che ai tempi di falcone
tutti si era convinti che fosse naturale
solo in alcune regioni
ora è chiaro a tutti che aver a che fare
con le mafie e naturale in tutta la
penisola
le mafie vedete sono riuscite a unire
l'italia
molto meglio di quello che hanno fatto
garibaldi mazzini cavour e tutti i
politici che sono susseguiti nella
nostra storia democratica
allora forse legalità non è soltanto un
concetto astratto legato alla giustizia
all'etica alla morale ma è un percorso
quotidiano fatto di costante impegno nel
rispetto delle norme e delle regole ma
anche di acquisizione di principi e di
valori
un percorso che deve vedere impegnati
tutti tutti i cittadini e tutte le
istituzioni
se le istituzioni non sono le prime ad
ari buon esempio
viene a mancare il rapporto di fiducia
con i cittadini
essenziale per creare percorsi di
legalità condivisi da tutta la società
per esempio se tra tutti gli attori
economici sociali politici di un
territorio manca la fiducia reciproca
qualsiasi protocollo di legalità
qualsiasi coordinamento alla legalità
resteranno inutile carta morta
praticare legalità significa anche
essere empatici
imparare prima di tutto a conoscere se
stessi ma anche gli altri
e cominciare a vedere negli altri
non solo un potenziale nemico ma anche
un possibile amico
non più un rapporto solo di controllore
controllato
ma un rapporto di collaborazione tra
pari che porti a obiettivi comuni
naturalmente ma per fare questo c'è
bisogno di competenze
figure credibili
persone coerenti evidente è vero quindi
che legale significa conforme alla legge
ma abbiamo visto che è anche qualcosa di
più profondo che permette a tutti noi di
comprendere tutti i nostri diritti tutti
i nostri doveri e anche quelli che sono
gli strumenti per fare rispettare questi
diritti e doveri legalità è quindi un
sentimento culturale
impossibile da spiegare ma che tutti noi
e tutte noi dobbiamo iniziare a
coltivare grazie
[Applauso]